aprobado el plan de infraestructura tras
meses de incertidumbre la cámara de
representantes estadounidense le dio el
visto bueno a uno de los pilares de la
campaña del presidente joe wagner el
proyecto de ley de infraestructura prevé
dedicar algo más de un billón de dólares
a la mejora de redes de transporte en
todo el país la ampliación de la
distribución de energía y el incremento
de la banda ancha de internet el segundo
proyecto de ley es un conjunto de
reformas más amplio se trata de su plan
de gasto social que constaría de 1.75
billones de dólares pero ha quedado
pospuesto hasta mediados de noviembre
hemos esperado bastante y esperábamos
aprobarla antes pero no podemos esperar
mucho más por la legislación de hoy sí
creo que hay un gran número de miembros
de caucus progresista que votarán para
aprobar este proyecto de ley
una cuarta parte del presupuesto para
gasto social se destinaría a la lucha
contra el cambio climático mientras que
otras propuestas incluyen la
financiación de la educación preescolar
universal un límite a los costes de las
guarderías el cuidado de los ancianos y
la inmigración reformas más difíciles de
aprobar con los publicanos unidos en la
oposición al proyecto de ley los
demócratas necesitarán casi todos los
votos a su alcance para que sea aprobado
por la cámara de representantes y los
demócratas moderados centristas
mantienen sus reservas y en una
estimación de costes no partidista antes
de decidir si respaldan el plan esa
estimación podría tardar hasta dos
semanas la aprobación del plan de
infraestructura constituye un triunfo
para joe biden quien esperaría una nueva
victoria con el plan de gasto social
para el día de acción de gracias